morgen früh unterwegs und wie sie
expedition in den unbekannte schweiz
alles
was ist und hoffe ich dass gott uns
vorstellen einen autoschlüssel gemeinsam
ist dass sie hier als irgendwie am
morgen am neulich mal wie viel der staat
muss irgend eines vermutlich im sport
lage ist programmiert 57 minuten vorher
richtig wäscht genaue ziel unbekannt
womit ein ausweg sehe dass ich meine
ohren auch irgendeine ahnung von
fussball noch morgengrauen benötigen
würden es geht nicht um sparen ist
staates sondern rechts im kanton waadt
[Musik]
doch zu einigen spendete das ist dass
ich großes industrieland
ab ins treibhaus
ok
foto wir nicht erwartet und das ist kein
fußball trainer
du bist ein großes loch warum heinz mehr
band jetzt vorstellte
das wird dem laufen heutigen tag noch
überraschend gut gebucht aber ich schon
mal als rohes spiel aber vielleicht
hatte aber nicht die arbeiter weiter gut
gemacht salat zum schnitte wird gemobbt
und da muss man frische anderen und das
ist autoritär hause
mona vetsch freitag in kiew nicht
vorbereitet auf alles gefasst
das ist mona mit drin
[Musik]
der börse cops niederbipp ist ein für
die größte mühe spuren von der schweiz
world access und folie tunnel hat einen
eigenen verpackungsanlage
und 150 hektar rhythmus im freiland und
darwin zum inspektor john mayer nicht so
schwierig sie
dank simon
cottbus muss weg und borsdorf der
beneteau ok jetzt ist ja das lebensmotto
des blatts wagner hatte mit seinem
schuss problem dass danach forderungen
abschnitte
okay das ist so kaputt machen und wenn
bürger schlechter waren marco hartmann
bleibt die wirtschaft dieser
weltcup-saison gewerbe drogen für dich
ich bin offen zu das macht
berlin adelino das ist der chef hat
gesagt du machst es ganz gut ich soll
bei dir ja und wie du es war also unter
profi aus pinto
also suche box
[Musik]
der erwerb ist ja
handarbeit alles nur der traktorist
satellit stört und sie jetzt förderband
stück für stück los
die einzige andere frau im salon der stv
aus portugal
ich bin froh und sie hat zwei sind und
das hier ist eine chance portugal und
die sind ja da sie sind in portugal
wieder bedient sich sehr herzlich
andere 40 jahre drama geschaffen
arbeitsbedingt geburt stadtlohn 1250
franken brutto im vergleich zu belohnen
ihre heimatstadt sechsfache
[Musik]
aber
du kannst du mir helfen ist kaputt ich
habe kaputt gemacht
nicht doch gut ist aber ein bisschen
kaputt doch schauen sie eigentlich schon
jetzt muss ich noch mal neues
neues machen
sechs punkten ist nicht so ganz oben
super
[Musik]
um viertel vor zwölf ist mittagspause
ich sitze zum hose und der christine an
sie sind sie - portugal wahrscheinlich
informatiker und sie medizin laborantin
[Gelächter]
mehr an diesen schäden in chips provinz
und wir machen uns nacht nicht
geschlafen
das liegt mir dafür vier mal gerufen
wird
wir schaffen zehn stunden tag und
samstagmorgen auf
ja
hallo
108 für die haupterntezeit von märz bis
november
vorher bin ich mir doch noch nie bereit
wäre eigentlich das gemüse ernten und
ich sagte umlauf
aber das ist egal
und da es auf dem feld auf arendt noch
für was die fußball stülpe sind ist
nicht als schutz gegen abreise noch viel
schnee wo sich entzünden
[Musik]
der startschuss jetzt gott so campbell
alle liegen am boden besonders viele
große schafft wie alle anderen stunde am
tag wieder buchen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es gibt auch offen zu gate die welt der
bösiger senior
der ruf arbeitete früher 9 bis 18 uhr
[Gelächter]
sind die frau oder herr schaffte trotz
pension jährige noch voll mit im betrieb
er im büro sie in hof locker
[Musik]
so marko
und da ist das bonus verbunden mit
seiner arbeit nicht stand das ist es so
einfach sagen egal ob das mitmachen und
freude bevor der zug und das manöver
wurzeln wurde peter angefangen hat -
pure sich alles noch ganz anders sie
bereits france klm mit einem treffen mit
dem frühen tod selbst wahnsinnig oder
wenn du denkst du schon so lange her
dass friend wird ausgerichtet vom
letzten 2 25 jahren
aber ich staune ich stand pure darlehens
ja das ganze land dass luft aus
landwirtschaft und im vergleich zu der
europäische konkurrenz zu ziehen und
kleine betriebe
sie zeigt mini unterkunft für die nacht
noch ein tag auf dem feld wenig schafft
zum glück nicht nur selber woche fiel
der aus moldawien und ihren rumänische
made sorin damit spontan zu uns nach die
dort studiert agronomie meinem beruf ist
er sich warten
ich staune wir sehen warum ist das doch
ich war übrigen das ist nicht mein land
nicht meine sprache von mir ist
schwerarbeit agronom und aber jungs oder
landeskliniken
warum gehen wir voran geht
wovon träumst du denn was was hast du
wie sieht dein leben aus in fünf jahren
oder zehn jahren gehe aber sowieso ich
komme in mailand eine landgemeinde tier
aber im moment ist gut aber du möchtest
dann in fünf jahren oder so wieder in
rumänien regierung kinder wir was wir
uns nicht alle besser so msi gibt es
noch ein gruß aus der heimat brennt vom
so ritter ich bin nicht nach hause
wie macht
danke für die einladung
und ich gut dankeschön
[Musik]
schlafen wie es vom rumänischen
zwetschge wasser bedeutet engel im 2
sexy dress gesanglich der chef bert
bösiger seid was und wie viel geerntet
wird
der zins- und philipp der wert wünscht
sich dass ehrenmorde betrieb übernimmt
ich kann nur mit aufs feld sondern ist
weg so auszudrücken
jetzt achtung
die wachsen so schnell gewachsen sind
also muss jeden tag mussten richtig
credo genau wie gewichts burg aber die
bourgeoisie zwischen 400 500 raum also
mitschnitte sind ab 24 jahren dass man
noch rechts laufbereich dieser
zertifizierung bekommen hat im laden
wenn simon im lager sieht das
unternehmen noch das sportgericht stufte
es darum setzt die 400 gramm gesetze ja
ich danke dir ja aber zum kontrollieren
immer wieder auf den modus macht mir
angst dass kurzes masse woche spitzte
das sponsoring plätzen überzeugen
und schon mal abschnitten und
kontrollieren ob das bist du bist hier
zu machen wir diese sollen im september
in alle welt offen kaufte war
wenn jetzt kontrolliert worden
nimmt man konnte die ganze woche so
schärfer kontrollieren und war wieder
bringen
aber mit der verpflichtung ihr da wird
die sagen
genau 44
jeder hier ist jetzt vom marketing
vorschriften sie schon so dass sie quasi
ganz so liegt die chronik dürfe sie aber
die europäischen vermarktungs freund von
macht eigentlich wichtig warum die ein
gott ich gerne sagen verständlich dass
es das ist ja das ist es absolut
qualität ist genau die gleiche ist der
griff nach gold oder her aber das ist ja
etwas absurd
aber woher er das jetzt natürlich im
verlauf der jahre entwickelt dort sollte
sie besser worte qualitativ besser
worten und matthias wahl zwischen gerade
großen und ganzen auch die genau wie ich
wenn ich hatte perfekte war dabei wohl
irgendwie einen einbruch
das ist menschlich
46 40 erfahrung von sieben jahre als
erntehelfer herzlich der manuell und
wirtschaft zum vorarbeiter im
gewächshaus er verpasst mir schnell
gleich bitte tomatenpflanze werden immer
wieder rufe bundes und am schluss
zusammen mit schneider bis ich schneide
und durchaus dass ich es richtig machen
ja ok
sicher sogar
also etwas was mir wirklich erklären
ich hatte sie das 7 7 verschiedene
pflanzen 89 meter und eigenwasser nach
lienen
das ist anders als unser einsteigern
steigungen wir frauen sind nie direkt in
dem staat wohl hilfen und da geht
sicherlich sagt er war es sei wohl so
ein ding und sie hat noch nie gesehen
haben natürlich weiß man hier darüber
sind dass eine haut die roboter pflanze
hat es in den roboter pflanze nährstoffe
nimmt pflanzen genau gleich ob sie in
gewachst oder ob sie steuer oder was
also gibt es keinen unterschied ob der
monastischen unterschied an großen
unterschied der genau wisse tomate
weniger wasser klären will pflanze nimmt
immer was und wenn ihr mich viel wasser
haben die zurecht gemacht wird und das
kann dauern natürlich viel genauer
studieren und das ganz wichtiger punkt
da wird dem zufall überlassen truppe
genau dass ihr temperaturen wächst
konstant 3 grad kühler als deuce
vor allem attacke wird gemäss einer ganz
genau kontrolliert was nicht passt wird
passend gemacht
[Musik]
der brief von kroes wird übrigens jeden
tag neue jungs kann wird für das ist der
hammer fulda zuständig sein job sei es
nicht billig aber nichtstun zu spät oder
funken
[Musik]
in der unterkunft vor der ernte helfen
sylvia marz nacht und ihren sohn in
david mit sich ziehen
[Musik]
die heiz rumänien hätte großes aquarium
aber doch im doppelzimmer headset platz
[Musik]
dober bitte portugiese ist es weniger
ruhig fußball-wm und portugal spielt der
ge spanien
[Applaus]
nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
brüssel dow jones --die portugiesische
kollegin friederike von drinks klar ist
nur ein kleiner betrieb sie mit
württemberg bösiger und neuerdings auch
im grossrat vom kanton bern ist muss
imperium
immer mehr organisationen verlangt
[Musik]
ich zeige
stimmt das ist schwierig etwas zu finden
betrieben feindschaft der hochzeit
positiv aus
nur kurt biedenkopf privatwirtschaft
läuft wieder besser
neben portugal oder in rumänien polen so
dass die notwendigen klasse heraus
baustoff betriebstätigkeit im ausland
nein das ist gar nicht mehr schweini
lied wo das war die arbeit macht zu den
bedingungen und dem ssv zurückfahren
sprachen den aber trifft das ist achter
limitierende faktor aber jetzt mit sco
themen wird nur bewahrt genauso vom mund
zu mund propaganda ihre verwandtschaft
mich noch nie so schlimm ich analog
stick oder du du bist ein grossrat für
das hatte und den parteien nicht nur
bekannt dass er gern ausländer in die
schweiz hat aber du brauchst auf dem hof
wie das mitdenken
das ist natürlich versuche einen
konflikt mit der situation mehr für
asylbewerber mir immer das potenzial
ausschöpfen schweizer im capitol
menschen noch nie eine lose vorträge mit
der administrative fahrer war sehr sehr
kompliziert
also ich habe
riesen und formt eine strategie der
grafschafter das heim gemerkt dass sie
auch sehr flüssige ritters gut mit den
habe ich sagen dass langsam aufgaben für
das ich wirklich leben
mit dem peter monika s park peterhof
lotte
der hofladen ist im ehemaligen kuhstall
bösiger sieg richtet das ist er ist iris
[Musik]
aber ich muss zwei wochen ferien und
dann machst du das macht mir aber jetzt
wird es gut aussieht
im lager seit dem auszug für tiere sind
fairer als alle andere freut sich aufs
wochenende
und bald ist es soweit dann stimmt alle
maschinen
das biz mehr als 24 stunden stehen
[Musik]
die letzten ort stellige mühelose
gleiten
armini schlomo mutter silvia sie mein
sport finish noch ein bisschen noch
ferien morgen oder zurück nach rumänien
zurück immer pläne für eine woche und
dann zurück
[Musik]
das ist das erste was du machst in
rumänien
ich muss treffen mit einer kreuzung mal
unterschreiben passiert würde
du und sorin zusammen ihr kauft er ist
ein haus dann kann ich gratulieren weil
dafür habt ihr so lange gearbeitet
erster stock und oben noch ein haus für
deine familie die hoffentlich nehmen
abschied von der silvia und annahmen
therapie bösiger dreieck im knast landet
dass ich die zukunft erklären warum
regal mit dem zug und tomate stand und
vielleicht bin ich da nicht ganz die
einzige
[Musik]